one of the few ethics that we've agreed
on in our society is don't go for people
for hardware issues so one of the
reasons among others which we agree that
it wouldn't be rude to somebody who's
disabled is it's not like they chose to
be disabled that's a hardware thing
there's nothing they could do about that
one of the things that's interesting in
the ethics we've been creating in the
west has been in recent years that
because of this a lot of issues are
auditioning to be seen as hardware
issues so
everything wants to be Hardware because
it's then harder to critique trans at
the moment is presenting itself as
Hardware because if it's Hardware who
would with no proof of Hardware oh no
proof of hardware and here's the really
difficult one is that trans says we're
Hardware at the same time as saying
being a woman is software
you can have one of those programs but
not both
you can't say the only people
legitimately born the way they are are
trans people